in this video I want to introduce you to
a mechanism called the aldol reaction
aldol reaction it's easily one of the
most important mechanisms and reactions
in all of organic chemistry because it's
a powerful way to actually create
carbon-carbon bonds and it'll actually
be a little bit of a review of what we
saw with enol and the enolate ions and
the the keto enol tautomer I have
trouble saying that anyway let's start
with let's start with a couple of
aldehydes and just for convenience I'll
make them identical so let's say that
this is one of the aldehydes it just has
a carbon chain there that's what the R
is it could be of any length who knows
what's there and then I have another
carbon here and then this is bound to
the carbonyl group and we're going to
make it an aldehyde although you could
do this reaction with a ketone as well
and just to make things clear this
carbon right here which is going to be
involved in a lot of the business here
let me draw its hydrogen's normally we
don't have to draw its hydrogen's and
just as a bit of review the carbon that
is next to the carbonyl carbon is called
an alpha carbon if this was a ketone
this would have also been an alpha
carbon if this was a carbon we're going
to see in this reaction besides just
exploring the reaction is that these
hydrogen's are actually much more acidic
than traditional hydrogen's attached to
carbons on the rest of the chain and it
comes from the fact that this this
proton can be given to something else
the electron can go to that carbon and
then it'll be resonance stabilized and
we're going to see that in a second now
I said I would draw two molecules of
that because we need two molecules
actually going to be to some degree
joining the two molecules so let me draw
another aldehyde right over here and I'm
going to draw it symmetric to this
because it'll make it very it'll make it
I think a little bit easier to visualize
the two molecules actually let me just
draw it let me just draw it the same way
so I'll draw in a different color so you
have the R group and then you have the
oxygen right there and I won't I won't
draw all of the hydrogen's on this guy
but this and this are the exact same
molecule it's just the hydrogen's are
implicit here now the aldol reaction
I'll show you will be in a basic
environment so you could imagine that we
have it'll be catalyzed by
I am bass and so imagine we have some
hydroxide laying around some of the
hydroxide anion hydroxide we do that in
a different color so let's say we have
some hydroxide anion floating around
negative charge just like that I just
told you that these hydrogen's are much
more acidic than hydrogen's anywhere
else on a carbon chain these alpha
hydrogen's so you could imagine a
situation where an electron from the
hydroxide is given to one of these
hydrogen protons and then then the
electron that was associated with that
hydrogen is now given back to this alpha
carbon and so if that were to happen the
next step in our reaction would look
like this and I'll draw it in
equilibrium actually let me draw it this
way so the next step in our a or the the
products of that step would be in
equilibrium with you have your carbon
chain or cart the rest of your molecule
right there's and that's just the show
that could be anything it's attached
here to the alpha carbon which is now
going to be negative I'll show that in a
second which is attached to the carbonyl
group which is attached to a hydrogen
and actually I'll I'll stop drawing that
hydrogen for now to just we know it's
there but I'll keep drawing this
hydrogen right over here the other
hydrogen was taken away and this alpha
carbon now has a negative charge because
it it got the electron from that proton
and of course we have the hydroxide
grabbed it grabbed this hydrogen and it
is now it is now water now the reason
why this was the reason why this was
acidic to begin with is because this is
resonance stabilized and I'll show you
that it's resonance stabilized right now
this alpha carbon right here can give
its electron to the carbonyl carbon and
if the carbonyl carbon gets an electron
it can give an electron to this oxygen
up here it'll break the double bond so
this configuration is resonance
stabilized is resonance stabilized with
this so I could draw it like
this you have your our and then you have
a single bond to this oxygen it now
gained an electron it is now negative
and you now have N and you now have a
double bond just like that and I could
draw this hydrogen if I like or I don't
have to it's implicitly over there now
and you might be familiar with this this
is the enol eight anion this right here
is the enolate enolate this is the
enolate ion if we had a hydrogen right
here it would be an enol and we would
say hey this is the keto form this is
the enol form we've seen this before now
what's interesting about the enolate ion
is it can act as a nucleophile it can do
a nucleophilic attack on the other on
the other aldehydes carbonyl group but
it does it in kind of a non-conventional
way and I'll show you how it does it
right now so it does the attack like
this so let me draw this guy over here
so you have the carbonyl group carbonyl
group and then then you have its alpha
carbon and then you have an R group
right over there there's actually a
hydrogen right over here as well I just
flipped it over this and this are the
same molecule but and let me make it
clear these two guys right here are
resonance forms and this is once again
this is the reason why it was it's
easier to take this hydrogen than other
hydrogens on a traditional carbon chain
easier to take an alpha hydrogen to a
carbonyl group because you have this
resonance structure but this enolate ion
especially this configuration of it you
can imagine it doing something like this
you can imagine this oxygen giving back
the electron to the carbonyl carbon to
this carbon right here and when that
happens then this then this guy this guy
is going to be giving up he's going to
be giving up an electron and that
electron that he gives up let me do it
in a new color this electron that he
gives up could go and do a nucleophilic
attack on this carbonyl group and so of
that if that carbonyl carbon gets let me
do this in a new color
if this carbonyl carbon gets an electron
then it could give away an electron to
that oxygen
right up there so the next step after
this we would have something like this
and once again I'll show it as happening
in equilibrium so from here we go right
over there
and what we have is a situation where
let me draw this guy on the Left first
so we have a double bond to this oxygen
now actually let me draw let me draw the
second so this is this oxygen we now
have a double bond
let me do it in this same purple color
right over here and then we have the
rest of what was an aldehyde what was an
aldehyde where you have let me do it in
that same color in that same color and
then you have your R group right over
there but now this electron get an
attack on this other aldehyde so this
guy right here this alpha carbon is that
same alpha carbon we've been dealing
with the same alpha carbon is now bonded
to this carbonyl carbon so it is now
bound to this carbonyl carbon right over
here and so it will look like this it
will look like let me draw it with the
right colors get the orange out so that
carbonyl carbon it now has a single bond
to this oxygen this electron was taken
back by it so this oxygen now has a
negative charge and it is bound to its
alpha carbon its alpha carbon and then
that is that is bonded to another
another group another probably a chain
of a carbon chain or something that
contains a carbon chain or another
functional group whatever you want to
call it and then the final step the
final step this anion can get rid of its
negative charge by essentially grabbing
a hydrogen from maybe this maybe from
this water that was formed before were
obviously not going to be the same
molecule but it could grab it from this
in a previous step this Mount water
molecule that was formed in a previous
step and of course this is all in a
basic environment so it can give an
electron to this hydrogen and then the
hydrogen would lose the hydrogen proton
would lose an electron to the hydroxide
and the hydroxide will become negative
again and so what will be the final
product
the final product will be the final
product and I'm just going to try my
best to redraw this thing right over
here you have this part of the molecule
so you have this carbonyl group right
over here it is attached to this radical
group right over there so that is this
part and I can even do the same colors
this bond right over here is this bond
right over here and then this this
carbon is attached to a carbon that's
attached to a hydroxyl group now so
it'll look like this and let me draw it
so this oxygen is now this oxygen and it
just captured this hydrogen so it is now
a hydroxyl group it's now and O H it is
now an OHA up and then finally this guy
is bound to what was an alpha carbon
it's not anymore what was an alpha
carbon which is then bound to a radical
group and if we want we can remember
that there was always from the get-go
there was always a hydrogen over here so
why is this called the aldol reaction
why does it matter well it's called the
aldol reaction because what we formed is
both an aldehyde notice this is an
aldehyde and it's an alcohol so that's
where the word aldol comes from but the
more important thing about this but you
know and and I don't want to mislead you
you could have also have done this with
a ketone you could have had a methyl
group or a ethyl group you could have a
big carbon chain here it still would
have worked so the aldol reaction
doesn't only form things that are
aldehydes and alcohols it could have
formed something that's both a ketone
and an alcohol but that's why it's
called the aldol reaction but the more
important thing about the aldol reaction
is one it shows you how the enol a dyon
can be a nucleophile it shows you why
the alpha hydrogen's are more acidic
than hydrogen's on other parts of carbon
chains but the most useful aspect of it
is it's a useful way to actually join
two carbon chains together notice we
were able to join this alpha carbon
right here to this carbonyl carbon over
here to form this aldol or sometimes
this will be called because
is still an alpha carbon right here this
is an alpha carbon this is a beta carbon
and so you'll sometimes this will be
referred to as a beta hydroxy and we've
probably used things from the from
convenient from the from the pharmacy
that that has this word in it this is
also called a beta hydroxy this alpha
this is beta has a hydroxyl group on the
beta carbon beta hydroxy aldehyde beta
hydroxy aldehyde anyway hopefully you
found that entertaining